ville parmi les plus visitées au monde
Paris et sans surprise une terre fertile
au développement de logements locatifs
de courte durée
pour vérifier la légalité des dizaines
de milliers d'appartements qui sont
loués la capitale s'est dotée d'une
équipe d'enquêteurs spécialisée environ
30 agents qui à l'occasion parcourt la
ville pour procéder à des vérifications
n'était pas actif mais il y a quand même
un locataire là-dedans à Paris une
résidence principale ne peut être louée
que 120 jours par année au propriétaire
quelques quelques pièces quelques
justificatifs
des appartements réservés sur les
plateformes comme Airbnb doivent aussi
être déclarés et enregistrées un cadre
que les agents rappellent aux
propriétaires qu'ils croisent en leur
distribuant de la documentation sur la
réglementation
interdit on a le droit dans la voilà
dans le respect de la réglementation on
peut le faire tout à fait dans cet
édifice en plein centre de la capitale
un indice attire l'attention des
enquêteurs alors ceux qu'on a vu là-haut
la boîte à clé ils sont pas déclarés
j'ai pas j'ai rien à ce nom-là donc
faudra faire une vérification
les dossiers qui contiennent au
règlement seront ensuite transmises à la
justice mais il faut d'abord préparer et
cibler ses interventions pour y parvenir
les équipes se basent sur des
signalements de voisins ou encore sur
des recherches qui sont menées en amont
le nombre de commentaires peut nous
orienter lorsqu'une annonce est déclarée
en meublé tourisme et qu'on observe
qu'il y a plus de commentaires que les
120 jours qui sont qui sont autorisés
pour une résidence principale et bien
évidemment ça n'ose oriente l'an dernier
des propriétaires fautifs ont du pays un
total de 2 millions 500 000 euros
d'amende l'équivalent de plus de 3
millions et demi de dollars canadiens
pour infraction règlement mais le
travail de la trentaine d'agents de la
ville de Paris n'est pas toujours simple
surtout dans une destination aussi
prisée des touristes
selon la ville 45000 annonces sont
actives uniquement sur la plateforme
Airbnb toutes ne peuvent pas être
vérifiées et la législation a parfois
une portée illimitée
des propriétaires qui évoluent par
exemple depuis quelques années on
observe de plus en plus de commerces
transformés en meublés tourisme alors
que jusqu'à lors c'était essentiellement
des logements qui étaient transformés en
meublés tourisme donc on a adopté de
nouvelles réglementations pour faire
face à cette évolution des stratégies
des investisseurs
puis sur le terrain l'accès aux
propriétés n’est pas toujours simple
contrairement aux facteurs ces agents de
la ville n'ont pas les clés ils doivent
souvent attendre qu'un résident les
laisse entrer
aussi de tomber sur des occupants aux
propriétaires peu réceptifs
visiblement agacé par cette visite
imprompue le pire c'est de mettre en
place des règles sans avoir des moyens
derrière pour vérifier qu'elles sont
appliquées le responsable du logement au
sein de l'administration municipale ne
cache pas ses objectifs ce sont des
règles qui visent à décourager la
transformation de logements en meublé
touristique nous manquons de logement et
nous nous travaillons pour l'intérêt
général et l'intérêt général dans une
ville comme Paris c'est qu'on puisse
loger ceux qui travaillent à Paris un
peu plus d'un an des Jeux Olympiques les
équipes de la ville ne manqueront pas de
travail de vérification les annonces à
des prix parfois exorbitants plus le
déjà sur les plateformes de réservation
et c'est rafale Bouvier au clair
Radio-Canada à Paris